je vous ai déjà expliqué je vous amène
la petite boîte qui forme c'est
peut-être la boîte qui leur sauvera la
vie en cas d'urgence avec à l'intérieur
un questionnaire
où il ya toutes les informations
concernant la santé de la personne cette
boîte jaune doit être placé dans le
frigo l'endroit n'est pas choisi au
hasard un frigo il y en a un dans chaque
foyer ce couple de retraités n'a pas
forcément de problème de santé mais
avoir cette boîte chez eux les rassure
on sait que quelqu'un peut nous prendre
en charge tout de suite grâce à ça si on
a du diabète si on a
une maladie cardiaque c'est marqué
dessus on est deux on peut se
débrouiller mais il suffit d'être absent
et qu'il arrive quelque chose tout de
suite mon mari raffin tout sous la main
à quelques kilomètres d'ici yvette vit
seule sur la porte d'entrée un
autocollant indiquent elles bénéficient
de ce système il guide les humains mais
peut aussi aider le membre de la famille
j'aime la belgique habite là alors c'est
bien ses besoins à revient ce très bien
ce que ça peut nous rendre service sur
tous nos que sa marge est donc ils font
tout seuls cette boîte est
principalement à destination des
personnes âgées mais pas seulement il ya
des jeunes qui ont des problèmes de
santé locales vont elles sont grosses
boîtes aussi parce que ça peut les aider
en cas de malaise dans le cher 15
communes bénéficient de ce dispositif
500 boîtes ont été commandés pour être
distribués je veux dire honteusement
nous avons copié sur des voisins mais il
n'y en avait pas dans le département du
cher la commission a découvert cette
initiative et l'on se dit c'était une
bonne idée et les bonnes idées s en fait
pour être reprise cette voie de jaune
permettra aux pompiers de gagner du
temps un temps précieux surtout en
milieu rural quand le centre de secours
est parfois éloignés des villages